it is Groundhog Day yes it is that time
of the year every year when I announced
that I am leaving Sky Sports and
Gillette soccer Saturday but this time
it is true 30 fantastic years on Skye
you a lot out there you've supported me
marvelously as have Skye it's time to
give you a break from all the VAR Rants
and the bad gags and the over-the-top
celebrations when Hartlepool score a
goal and give somebody else a chance to
do this fantastic job so leaving on May
the 28th we've got a few programs
between now and then this is the last
six hour Saturday Gillette soccer
Saturday so we better get on with it
haven't we
no thank you boys thank you very much